-Finally, you guys,
spring is here.
Okay? Are you feeling this?
The weather...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The weather is warming up.
The flowers are in full bloom,
which inspired me
to write a song
with one of our good friends,
Andy Samberg.
Here, take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ I'm a plant dad ♪
♪ I love plants ♪
♪ Water them, sun them,
do a little dance ♪
-♪ I'm a plant dad ♪
♪ Plants love me ♪
♪ Dig them, raise them,
one, two, three ♪
-♪ Go into the garden,
get on my knees ♪
♪ Give a little drink
to my bonsai trees ♪
-♪ I've got my pot,
I've got my seeds ♪
♪ I give little kisses
to the itty-bitty leaves ♪
-♪ Fill a whole hothouse,
that's my dream ♪
♪ I like to go green,
if you know what I mean ♪
-♪ I know what you mean ♪
♪ I love plants, too ♪
♪ My wife is leaving me
for another man ♪
-♪ I'm a plant dad,
I love plants ♪
♪ Water them, sun them,
do a little dance ♪
-♪ I'm a plant dad ♪
♪ Plants love me ♪
♪ Dig them, raise them,
one, two, three ♪
-♪ Succulents don't need
that much water ♪
♪ And they like to live
where it's much hotter ♪
-♪ Caring for plants,
it gives me structure ♪
♪ She had an affair
with her yoga instructor ♪
-♪ I can't get enough
of my orchids ♪
-♪ She and Braden want
to have more kids ♪
-♪ Sprouts are short,
plants are long ♪
-♪ I'm afraid of Braden,
he seems strong ♪
-♪ One plant D-A-D I be ♪
-♪ My kids already
call him daddy ♪
-♪ So -- ♪
-♪ Couples therapy ♪
♪ Then went badly ♪
♪ She said I tried to coop
her up like Bradley ♪
♪ Then she also said
she slept with Bradley ♪
she slept with Chad Lee ♪
♪ I said, even so,
I love her madly ♪
♪ Then the therapist
called me a simp ♪
♪ She said
take some time to self-reflect ♪
♪ And, quote unquote,
find some self-respect ♪
♪ But instead I went straight
to my former house ♪
♪ In search of my soon-to-be
former spouse ♪
♪ I dropped to my knees
and begged her please ♪
♪ To be in a throuple with me ♪
♪ They politely passed
after thinking it through ♪
♪ They said,
We're open to a throuple ♪
♪ Just not with you,
which hurt ♪
♪ So I walked down the block ♪
♪ I came back later,
but they changed the lock ♪
♪ So I burrowed a hole
underneath the house ♪
♪ And lay there all night,
quiet as a mouse ♪
♪ Listening to them bone ♪
-Should --
Should I, like, go?
-♪ As I lay there,
buried like a plant ♪
♪ I can hear them grunt,
I can hear the pant ♪
♪ The sweat drips
down through the floorboards ♪
♪ Onto my forehead ♪
♪ I can hear four words ♪
♪ They are worthless, worthless,
worthless, worthless ♪
♪ Why am I here?
What is my purpose? ♪
♪ Smile on my face,
but my laugh is mirthless ♪
♪ I just have to be down
where the dirt is ♪
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪ I'm a plant dad,
I love plants ♪
♪ Water them, sun them,
do a little dance ♪
♪ I'm a plant dad,
plants love me ♪
♪ Every plant I ever raised
[bleep] died ♪
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-The one and only Andy Samberg
right there!
Check out his new show,
"Digman!"
airing Wednesdays at 10:30
on Comedy Central.
We love you, Andy.